Universal's "The Last Voyage of the
Demeter" bombed at the box office after
it opened on August 11. So why did the
"Dracula on a boat" flick flop so hard?
"Demeter" netted $6.5 million on its
first weekend in theaters, making back
just a fraction of its $45 million budget.
Perhaps the most immediate culprit behind its
lackluster financial performance is its lukewarm
reception from critics. On Rotten Tomatoes, the
film sits at 51% from professional reviewers and
a still unimpressive 74% from audiences at large,
as of the making of this video. In his review
for Variety, for example, Owen Gleiberman wrote,
"'The Last Voyage of the Demeter' is too explicit,
too dawdling yet rapid-fire, too
much like other horror films."
Critics weren't wholly unkind, however —
RogerEbert.com reviewer Peter Sobczynski
awarded it three-and-a-half stars
out of a possible four, writing,
"It is a smart, well-made, and sometimes
downright creepy take on the tale that both
horror buffs and regular moviegoers
can appreciate in equal measure."
"We call him Dracula."
But bad reviews alone aren't typically
enough to keep viewers away from an
otherwise interesting release, suggesting
that at least a couple other key factors
beyond just its critical reception played a
part in the film's subpar box office haul.
Before taking into account how reviewers received
"Demeter," a multitude of factors regarding its
promotion and release made its success an uphill
battle prior, even, to its theatrical premiere.
Chief among what might be considered
marketing failures is the fact that the
film's title doesn't accurately reflect its
biggest selling point. "The Last Voyage of
the Demeter" is technically a classic Dracula
movie, adapting a chapter from Bram Stoker's
genre-defining vampire novel. Its title,
however, simply evokes a journey at sea,
leaving casual viewers unaware
that it's actually a Dracula story.
Several international markets feature distinctive
names for the film that take advantage of the
name-recognition that Dracula has. For example, in
Australia, the film is titled "Dracula: Voyage of
the Demeter," a far more inviting name that paints
a clearer picture as to what audiences can expect.
Universal also decided to release a horror movie
in August, a couple months before spooky movie
season officially kicks off near the start of
October. Not only is this timing not ideal,
but it falls squarely in the midst
of "Barbenheimer" mania, during which
theater-goers are still more likely to see either
of those two box office giants than an ill-timed
horror movie that bewilderingly buries the fact
that it's about fiction's most iconic vampire.
"So cool."
While it's difficult to deny the
competition "Demeter" faced from
both "Barbie" and "Oppenheimer," it should
be noted that the Universal Pictures flick
wasn't the only horror film competing for the
attention of audience members at the multiplex.
During the Dracula film's opening weekend,
audiences had multiple options to choose from.
During its debut weekend, "Demeter"
faced competition from both Disney's
"Haunted Mansion" and A24's "Talk to Me."
They made $5.7 million and $5.1 million,
respectively, almost in line with the
Dracula film's $6.5 million debut.
When it came to that weekend's horror
offerings, the trio definitely cannibalized
one another. While "Demeter" technically
took the higher spot of the three,
it's clear the crowded horror landscape robbed
the Dracula film of a potential $10 million debut.
"Haunted Mansion" appeals to
both families and teenagers,
thanks in part to its PG-13 rating.
Seeing as "Demeter" boasts an R-rating,
a portion of prospective viewers likely
went with Disney's haunted offering. The
R-rated "Talk to Me," meanwhile, is thriving,
thanks to positive word of mouth and reviews.
"Demeter" was the new film in cinemas, but it was
arguably the least interesting, at least from the
audience's perspective. Paying cinemagoers gave
the Dracula film a B- CinemaScore, signaling mixed
to negative word of mouth. "Haunted Mansion" and
"Talk to Me," meanwhile, boast B+ CinemaScores.
Perhaps "Demeter" would have shined earlier in
the summer, when horror films were more scarce.
Even if international audiences were interested
in seeing "The Last Voyage of the Demeter," key
markets weren't given the opportunity to do
so. The film's release in the United Kingdom
has been delayed indefinitely thanks
to eOne shutting down operations in
the country. With eOne now sold to Lionsgate,
"Demeter" has lost a distributor in the UK.
"May God have mercy on us all!"
Only time will tell if the Universal project
will receive a theatrical release in the UK.
Seeing as how "Demeter" features a largely Irish
cast and with a majority of the story dependent on
UK locations, it must be difficult for Universal
Pictures to bid farewell to such a key territory.
Other international markets haven't
received the film as of yet. /Film
reports that the flick is slated to debut
in Spain and India, though no official
release dates have been given. With the film
bombing stateside, it remains to be seen if
Universal Pictures will move forward with
international releases or cut their losses.
A few months before "Demeter" premiered
in theaters, Universal's previous vampire
movie "Renfield" also bombed. This
was sort of a canary in the coal mine,
foretelling its successor's
lack of box office success.
"Renfield" stars Nicholas Hoult as R. M.
Renfield, a character straight out of Bram
Stoker's "Dracula" novel. Similarities to its
literary source material pretty much start and
stop there, however, given that "Renfield"
is a quirky comedy set in the present day.
Audiences were ultimately uninterested in
this twist on the classic Dracula formula,
leaving its total box office haul
short of even half its budget.
That "Demeter" is on track to fare worse is
hardly surprising, then, given how "Renfield"
demonstrated that its overarching formula
isn't something most theater-goers want to
see. And whereas "Renfield" stars big names
like Hoult, Awkwafina, and Nicholas Cage,
"Demeter" is absent a marquee star to make up
for its core concept failing to draw viewers.
This phenomenon, in fact, extends past just
vampire movies. Both Guy Ritchie's "King Arthur:
Legend of the Sword" and the 2018 "Robin
Hood" film — while not quite on the same
level — failed to make back their budgets as
well, further indicating that audiences don't
care about contemporary spins on classic
material as much as studios seem to think.